you pulled a fast one on us though
everybody it's Simon and the fact that
we were able to keep it a secret
assignment that was by the way brilliant
it's the production they kept me like
sequestered I mean I was only rehearsing
on stage when I was with the light
balance kids and otherwise they had me
hidden in a room I was really blessed to
be able to work with those kids they're
amazing I mean you believe it I know you
have obviously fostered a lot of young
dancers throughout your career how
amazing was it to share that stage with
them but also do something that you've
never done before the amount of work
that goes into the technology of
performing with the light balance but
every single one of those kids were
stellar they were so supportive of me it
was so cute they're like don't be
nervous I hope they were telling you
that they're telling Paul Abdul that I
said don't worry don't worry I'm not
gonna be nervous they were so sweet so
cute
so Simon had no clue Simon had no clue
I'm telling you was the funniest thing
he did actually did a double taking he's
smiling he's popping it in it was anyway
like he was shocked and he couldn't
believe that it was kept a secret from
oh really though cuz that he obviously
is the he's the captain of this ship you
know but it's so funny because I was
talking to him recently and he's saying
he's dying to do something with you and
Randy again a little did he know you'd
be back at AGT but any chances you guys
will collab on something very very soon
according to Simon yes so I can't wait
to he's hopping around you and I meet
with him
once the show is over what was it like
reuniting with Kelly Clarkson and the og
idols Kelly she's a natural and it was
so fun it just was like a love fest
you know you never you'll never forget
the very first season and being able to
find talent I liked Kelly that was
incredible season having Justin come on
her show with us was fun
it's like it's it's wonderful I'm so
happy special a nostalgic but such a
pleasure to see great job
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]